how hard is it to build the metaverse
what is the metaverse in your view you
started with discussing and thinking
about quake as a kind of a metaverse
as you think about it today what is the
metaverse the thing that could create
this compelling user value this
experience that will change the world
and how hard is it to build it
so the term comes from neil stephenson's
book snow crash which many of us had
read back in the 90s it was one of those
kind of formative books
and there was this sense that
the
the possibilities and kind of the the
freedom and unlimited capabilities to
build a virtual world that that does
whatever you want whatever you ask of it
has been a powerful draw for generations
of developers you know game developers
specifically and people that are
thinking about more
more general purpose applications
so we were talking about that back in
the doom and quake days about how do you
wind up with an interconnected set of
worlds that you kind of visit from one
to another and as web pages were
becoming a thing you start thinking
about how what is the interactive kind
of 3d based equivalent of this and there
were a lot of really bad takes you had
like verbal then
virtual reality markup languages and
there's aspects like that that
that came from people saying well what
would what kind of capabilities should
we develop to
to enable this and that kind of
capability first work has usually not
panned out very well
uh on the other hand we have successful
games that started with things like doom
and quake and communities that formed
around those and uh whether it was
server lists in the early days or you
know literal portaling between different
games and then modern things that are on
completely different order of magnitude
like minecraft and fortnite that have
100 million plus users
um
you know i still think that that's the
right way to go to build the metaverse
is you build something that's amazing
that people love and people wind up
spending all their time in uh because
it's awesome and you expand the
capabilities of that so yeah even if
it's a very basic experience
minecraft is minecraft is an amazing
case study in so many things
basically what's able to be done with
that is really
enlightening and there are other cases
where like right now roblox is basically
a game construction kit aimed at kids
and that was a capability first play and
it's achieving scale that's on the same
order of those things so
it's not impossible but my preferred bet
would be you make something amazing that
people love and you make it better and
better and that's where i could say we
could have gone back and followed a path
kind of like that in the early days if
you just kind of take the same game
whether it's when activision
demonstrated that you could make call of
duty every year and not only is it not
bad people kind of love it and it's a
it's very profitable the idea that you
could have taken something like that
take a great game
release a new version every year that
lets the capabilities grow and expand to
start saying it's like okay it's a game
about running around and shooting things
but now you can have i bring your media
into it you can i add persistence of
social sense sign of signs of life or
whatever you want to add to it i i still
think that's you know quite a good uh
position to take and i think that while
metta is doing a bottoms-up capability
approach with horizon worlds where it's
a fairly general purpose creators can
build whatever they want in their sort
of thing
i am you know it's it's hard to compare
and compete with something like fortnite
which also has enormous amounts of
creativity even though it was not
designed originally as a general purpose
sort of thing
so there's we have examples on both
sides me personally i would have bet on
uh trying to do entertainment valuable
destination first and expanding from
there so
can you imagine the thing that will be
kind of if we look back a couple of
centuries from now
and you think about the
experiences that marked the singularity
the transition
in
where most of our world moved into
virtual reality what do you think those
experiences will look like
so i do think it's going to be kind of
like the way the web
slowly took over where you're you're the
the frog in the pot of water that's
slowly heating up where having lived
through all of that i remember when it
was shocking to start seeing uh seeing
the first website address on a billboard
when you're like hey my computer world
is in infecting the real world you know
this is spreading out
in some way but they're still when you
look back and say well what what made
the web take off and it wasn't a big
bang sort of moment there it was a bunch
of little things that turned out not
even be the things that are relevant now
that brought them into it so well i
wonder if from i mean like you said
you're not a historian
so maybe there's a historian
out there that could really identify
that moment the data-driven way it could
be like myspace or something like that
maybe the first major social network
that really reached into
non-geek world or something like that i
think that's kind of the fallacy of
historians though looking for some of
those kind of primary dominant causes
where so many of these things are like
we see an exponential curve but it's not
because like one thing is going
exponential it's because we have
hundreds of little sigmoid curves
overlapped on top of each other and they
just happen to keep adding up so that
you've got something kind of going
exponential at any given point but not
no single one of them was the critical
thing there were you know dozens and
dozens of things i mean seeing the
transitions of stuff like as obviously
myspace giving way to other things but
even like blogging giving way to uh to
social media and getting resurrected in
other guises and then means things that
happened there dancing baby gif or
whatever the all all your base now
belong to us whatever those early memes
that led to the modern memes and the
humor on the different the different
evolution of humor on the internet that
i'm sure the historians will also write
books about
uh from the different websites that
support to create the infrastructure for
that humor like reddit and all that kind
of stuff
so people will go back and they will
name firsts and critical moments but
it's probably going to be a poor
approximation of what actually happens
and we've already seen like in the vr
space where
it didn't play out the way we thought it
would in terms of what was going to be
like when
the modern era of vr basically started
with my e3 demo of doom 3 on the rift
prototype so we're like first person
shooters in vr match made in heaven
right
and that didn't work out that way at all
they have you know they have the most
comfort problems with it and then the
most popular virtual reality app is beat
saber which nobody predicted back then
what's that make you
uh like
from first principles if you were to
like reverse engineer that why
are these like silly fun games the most
it actually makes very clear sense when
you when you analyze it from from
hindsight and look at the engineering
reasons where it's not just that it was
a magical quirky idea it was something
that played almost perfectly to what
turned out to be the real strengths of
vr where the one thing that i really
underestimated importance in vr was the
importance of the controllers you know i
was still thinking we could do a lot
more with with the gamepad and just the
amazingness of taking any existing game
being able to move your head around and
look around that that was you know that
was really amazing but the controllers
uh were super important but the problem
is so many things that you do with the
controllers just suck it feels like it
breaks the illusion like trying to pick
up glasses with the controllers where
you're like oh use the grip button when
you're kind of close and it'll snap into
your hand all of those things are
unnatural
actions that you do them and it's still
part of the vr experience
but
beat saber winds up i playing only to
the strengths it completely hides all
the weaknesses of it because you are
holding something in your hand you keep
a solid grip on it the whole time it
slices through things without ever
bumping into things you never get into
the point where you know i'm knocking on
this table but in vr my hand just goes
right through it so you've got something
that slices through so it's never your
brain telling you oh i should have hit
something you've got a lightsaber here
it's just you expect it to slice through
everything
uh audio and music turned out to be a
really powerful aspect of virtual
reality where you're blocking the world
off and constructing the world around
you
and i
and being something that can run
efficiently on even this relatively
low-powered hardware and can have a
valuable loop in a small amount of time
where a lot of modern games you're
supposed to sit down and play it for an
hour just to get anywhere sometimes a
new game takes an hour to get through
the tutorial level and that's not good
for vr for a couple reasons you do still
have the comfort issues if you're moving
around at all but you've also got just
you know discomfort from the headset
battery life span on the mobile versions
so having things that do break down into
three and four minute windows of play
that turns out to be very valuable from
a gameplay standpoint
so it winds up being kind of a perfect
storm of all these things that are
really good it doesn't have any comfort
problems you're not navigating around
you're standing still all the stuff
flies at you it has placed audio
strengths i it adds the whole fitness in
vr nobody was thinking about that back
in the at the beginning and it turns out
that that is an excellent daily fitness
thing to be doing if you go play uh an
hour of beat saver or supernatural or
something that is legit solid exercise i
and it's more fun than doing it just
about any other way there so that's kind
of the arcade stage of things
if i were to say with my experience with
vr
the thing that i think is powerful is
the
maybe it's not here yet
but the degree to which it is immersive
in the way
that quake is immersive it takes you to
another world for me because i'm a fan
of role playing games
uh the elder scrolls series uh like
skyrim or even daggerfall it just takes
you to another world and when you're not
in that world you miss not being there
and then you just you kind of want to
stay there forever because life is
shitty
the whole thing when you just want to go
to the place is that i there was a
there was a time when i we were kind of
asked to come up with like what's your
view about vr
and i am you know my pitch was that it
should be better inside the headset than
outside it's the world as you want it
yeah and everybody thought that was
dystopian and like that's like oh you're
just gonna forget about the world
outside and i don't get that mindset
where the idea that if you can make the
world better inside the headset than
outside
you've just improved the person's life
that's has a headset that can wear it
and there are plenty of things that we
just can't do for everyone in the real
world everybody can't have richard
branson's private island but everyone
can have a private vr island and it can
have the things that they want on it and
there's a lot of these kind of rivalrous
goods in the real world that vr can just
be better at we can do a lot of things
like that that can be very very rich so
yeah i want the i think it's going to be
a positive thing this world where people
want to go back into their headset where
it can be better than somebody that's
living in a tiny apartment can have a
palatial estate in virtual reality they
can have all their friends from all over
the world come over and visit them
without everybody getting on a plane and
i and meeting in some place and dealing
with all the other logistics hassles
there is real value in the
you know the presence that you can get
for remote meetings it's
it's all the little things that we need
to sort out but those are things that we
have line of sight on people you know
that have been in like a good vr meeting
using workrooms where you can say oh
that was better than a zoom meeting but
of course it's more of a hassle to get
into it not everyone has a headset
interoperability is worse you can't have
you cap out at a certain number there's
all these things that need to be fixed
but that's one of those things you can
look at and say we know there's value
there we just need to really grind hard
to file off all the rough edges and make
that possible so you do think we have
line of sight
because
there's a there's a reason
like i i do this podcast in person for
example
doing it remotely it's not the same and
if you if somebody were to ask me why
it's not the same i wouldn't be able to
write down exactly why
um but you're saying
that it's possible whatever the magic is
for in-person interaction
that immersiveness of the experience
we are almost there yes so the idea of
like i'm doing a vr interview with
someone i'm not saying it's here right
now but you can see glimmers of what it
should be and we largely know what would
need to be fixed and improved to like
you say there's a difference between a
remote interview doing a podcast over
zoom or something and face to face
there's that sense of presence that
immediacy the super low latency
responsiveness being able to see all the
subtle things there just occupying the
same field of view and all of those are
things that we absolutely can do in vr
and that simple case of a small meeting
with a couple people that's the much
easier case than everybody thinks the
ready player won multiverse with a
thousand people going across a you know
a huge bridge to amazing places that's
harder in a lot of other technical ways
not to say we can't also do that but
that's further away and has more
challenges but this small thing about
being able to have a meeting with
one or a few people and have it feel
real feel like you're there uh like you
have the same interactions and talking
with them you get subtle cues as we
start getting eye and face tracking and
some of the other things on high-end
headsets
a lot of that is going to come over
and it doesn't have to be as good this
is an important thing that people miss
where
there was a lot of people that
especially rich people that would look
at vr and say it's like oh this just
isn't that good and i'd say it's like
well you've already been courtside
backstage and you know on pit row and
you've done all of these experiences
because you get to do them in real life
but most people don't get to and even if
the experience is only half as good if
it's something that they never would
have gotten to do before it's still a
very good thing and as we can just we
can push that number up over time it has
a minimum
viable value level when it does
something that is valuable enough to
people as long as it's better inside the
headset on any metric than it is outside
and people choose to go there we're on
the right path and we have a value
gradient that i'm just always hammering
on we can just follow this value
gradient just keep making things better
rather than going for that one close
your eyes swing for the fences uh kind
of
silver bullet approach well i wonder if
there's a value gradient for in-person
meetings because if you get that right
i mean that would change the world yeah
it doesn't need to
i mean you don't need uh ready player
one i but
i wonder if there's that value gradient
you can follow along
because
if there is and you follow it then there
will be a certain like phase shift
that's a certain point where people will
shift from um
from zoom to this
i wonder
what what are the bottlenecks is it
software is it hardware is it like is it
is it all about latency so i have big
arguments internally about strategic
things like that where i
like the next headset that's coming out
and that we've made various
announcements about is going to be a
higher end headset more expensive more
features lots of people want to make
those those trade-offs i you know we'll
see what the market has to say about the
the exact trade-offs we've made here but
if you want to replace zoom you need to
have something that everybody has i'm
and so you like cheaper i like cheaper
because also
lighter and cheaper wind up being uh a
virtuous cycle there where
expensive and more features tends to
also lead towards heavier and it just
kind of goes it's like let's add more
features the features are not i
you know they have physical presence and
weight and draw from batteries and all
of those things so i've always favored a
lower end a cheaper faster approach
that's why i was always behind the
mobile side of vr rather than the higher
end pc headsets and i think that's you
know that's proven out well
but there's i you always ideally we have
a whole range of things but if you've
only got one or two things it's
important that those two things cover
the uh you know the scope that you think
is most important when we're in a world
when it's like cell phones and there's
50 of them on the market covering every
conceivable ecological niche you want
that's going to be great but we're not
going to be there for a while where the
bottlenecks
is it the hardware of the software yeah
so right now i
you can play you can get uh workrooms on
quest and you can set up these things
and it's a pretty good experience it's
surprisingly good i haven't tried it
it's surprisingly good
the voice latency is better on that than
a lot better than a zoom meeting so
you've got a more a better sense of
immediacy there the expressions that you
get from the the current hardware with
just kind of your controllers and your
head is pretty realistic feeling you've
got a pretty good sense of being there
with someone are these like uh
avatars of people like do you do do you
get to see their body yeah
and they're sitting around a table yeah
and it feel it feels
better than zooming better than you yeah
better than you'd expect for that it is
definitely
yeah i'd say it's it's quite a bit
better than zoom when everything's
working right but there's still all the
rough edges of the reason zoom became so
successful is because they just nailed
the usability of everything it's high
quality with a absolutely first rate
experience and we are not there yet with
any of the vr stuff i'm trying to to
push hard to get
i i keep talking about it's like it
needs to just be one click to make
everything happen and we're getting
there in our our home environment not
the whole work rooms application but the
main home where you can now kind of go
over and click an invite and it still
winds up taking five times longer than
it should but we're getting close to
that where you click there they click on
their button and then they're sitting
there in this good presence with you but
latencies need to get a lot better user
interface needs to get a lot better um
ubiquity of the headsets needs to get
better we need to have 100 million of
them out there just so that everybody
knows somebody that uses this all the
time well i think it's a virtual cycle
because i do think
the interface
is the thing that makes or breaks
this kind of revolution it's so
interesting how like uh you said one
click but it's also like how you achieve
that one click
i don't know what is um
can i ask a dark question maybe let's
keep it outside of meta but
this is about meta but also google and
big company
are they able to do this kind of thing
it seems like
let me put on my cranky old manhattan is
they seem to
not do a good job of
creating these user-friendly interfaces
as they get bigger and bigger as a
company like google has created some of
the greatest interfaces ever
uh early on and it's i mean creating
gmail
just so many brilliant
interfaces and it just seems to be
getting crappier and crappier at that
same with meta same with uh
microsoft it's just it seems to get
worse and worse at that as this i don't
know what is it because you've become
more conservative careful risk-averse
is that why
can you speak to that then really
eye-opening to me working inside a tech
titan where
i am you know i i had my small companies
and then we're acquired by a you know a
mid-sized game publisher
and then uh oculus getting acquired by
meta and meta has grown by a factor of
many just in the the eight years since
the acquisition
so i did not have experience with this
and it's it was interesting because i
remember like previously my benchmark
for uh kind of use of resources was some
of the government programs i interacted
with on the aerospace side and i
remember thinking there was okay there's
an air force program and they spent 50
million dollars and they didn't they
didn't launch anything they didn't even
build anything it was just kind of like
they i you know they made a bunch of
papers and had some parts in uh in a
warehouse and nothing came of it it's
like 50 million dollars
i am and i have i've had to radically
recalibrate my sense of like how much
money can be spent with uh without a
product at the end of resources
where
on the ver the plus side vr has turned
out we've built pretty much exactly what
you know we just passed the 10-year mark
then from my like my first demo of the
rift and if i could have said what i
wanted to have it would have been a
standalone inside out tracked 4k
resolution headset that i that could
still plug into a pc for high-end
rendering and that's exactly what we've
got on quest two right now first of all
let's pause on that with me being cranky
and everything it's what meta achieved
uh with oculus and so on is incredible
i mean this is
this
when i thought about the future of vr
that's what i imagined in terms of
hardware i would say and maybe in terms
of the experience as well but it's still
not there somehow
on the one hand we did kind of achieve
it and win and we've got we've sold you
know we're a success right now but
the amount of resources that have gone
into it it winds up getting clouded up
in accounting where mark did announce
that they spent 10 billion dollars a
year like on reality labs now reality
labs covers a lot it was vr was not the
large part of it also had portal and
spark and the big ar research efforts
and it's been expanding out to include
ai and other things there where
uh there's a lot going on there but 10
billion dollars was just a number that i
had trouble processing it's just i feel
sick to my stomach thinking about that
much money being spent but that's how
they they demonstrate commitment to this
where it's not i'm
more so than like yeah google goes and
cancels all of these projects
different things i like that while meta
is really sticking with the funding of
vr and ar is still further out with it
so there's something to be said for that
um it's not just going to vanish the
works going in i just wish it could be
all those resources could be applied
more effectively because i see all these
cases i point out these examples of how
a third party that we're kind of
competing with in various ways there's a
number of these examples and they do
work with a tenth of the people that we
do internally
uh and a lot of it comes from yes
there's the small company can just go do
it while in a big company you do have to
worry about i you know is there some sdk
internally that you should be using
because another team is making it you
have to have your cross-functional group
meetups for different things you do have
more concerns about you know about
privacy or diversity and equity and
safety of different things parental
issues and things that a small startup
company can just kind of you know cowboy
often do something interesting and
there's a lot more
that is a problem that you have to pay
attention to in the big companies but
i'm not willing to believe that we are
within even a factor of two or four of
what the efficiency could be you know i
i am constantly
kind of crying out for it's like we can
do better than this and you wonder what
the mechanisms to unlock that efficiency
are you know i i don't
there is some sense in a large company
that
like an individual engineer might not
believe that they can change the world
maybe you you delegate a little bit of
the
responsibility to be the one who changes
the world in a big company i think but
the reality is
like the world will get changed by a
single engineer anyway
so if whether inside google or inside a
startup it doesn't matter it's just like
google and meta needs to help those
engineers believe
they're the ones that are going to
decrease that latency it'll take one
john carmack like the 20 year old
carmack
that's inside meta right now to change
everything and i try to point that out
and push people it's like try to go
ahead and when you see something because
there is you get the silo mentality
where you're like okay i know
something's not right over there but
that's i'm staying in my lane here i
and there's there's a couple people that
i can you know i can think about that
are willing to just like hop all over
the place and man i treasure them the
people that are just willing to they're
fearless you know they will go over and
they will go rebuild the kernel and
change this distribution and go in and
hack the firmware over here to to get
something done right and that is
relatively rare you know there's
thousands of developers and you've got a
small handful that are willing to
operate at that level and you know and
it's potentially risky for the the
politics are you know are real in a lot
of that and i'm in the you know very
much the privileged position of
i am you know i'm more or less
untouchable there where i've been dinged
like twice for it's like you said
something insensitive in that post and i
and you should probably not say that i
am but for the most part yes i you know
i get away with i every week i'm posting
something you know pretty loud and
opinionated in you know internally and i
think that's useful for the company
but i'm
yeah it's not if it's rare to have a
position like that and i can't
necessarily offer advice for how someone
can do that i well you could offer
advice to a company in general to give a
little bit of freedom
for the young wild the wildest ideas
come from
the young minds
uh and so you need to give the young
minds freedom to to think big and wild
and and crazy and for that they have to
be opinionated they have to be
um they have to think crazy ideas and
thoughts and pursue them with a full
passion without being slowed down by
bureaucracy or managers and all that
kind of stuff
obviously startups really empower that
but big companies could too and that's
that's a design challenge for company
for big companies to see how can you
enable that how can you possibly big
company there are so many resources
there and they do you know amazing
things do get accomplished but
there's so much more that could come out
of that and you know i'm hope i'm always
hopeful i'm an optimist in almost
everything you know i think things can
get better i think that they can improve
things that you go through a path and
you're learning kind of what does and
doesn't work and i'm not i'm not ready
to be fatalistic about the kind of the
outcome of any of that uh me neither i
know too many good people inside of
those large companies that are
incredible
you